[Music]
and the sky was you you're gonna die oh
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] Korean nucleus
smoke coming at you tonight
it's Monday night strap on your seatbelt
[ __ ] director the rest from North
Korea I got the weed growing in the
patch when they grow the rocket ships
it's all over we're going deep tonight
if you're under 18 go [ __ ] yourself I
don't want you seeing this you little
pricks
we got everything tonight look at this
we got mushrooms we got [ __ ] decals
we got [ __ ] scars of death
wait till you see this you [ __ ]
[ __ ] lettuce BAM look at this
[ __ ] the rocket ship here this is a
[ __ ] meteor or a debt can you imagine
this ticking this up your girlfriend's
[ __ ] and need her little monkey
should be dizzy for a week and [ __ ]
lettuce that's some [ __ ] reef right
the Voodoo Lounge come suckers don't
worry about when we get an [ __ ] I've
done crazier things you don't say
[Music]
oh [ __ ] is gonna be an ugly night
I'm telling you [ __ ] right now
please already sweating the party has
not even started yet but don't worry
about nothing I got you you'll be fine
we have some intravenous don't have
anything you don't know how to take me
with the needle Eve I got some coconut
water I got coconut water is just like
an intravenous they used it during the
Korean War did you know that every time
Tony got shot issues in secret use
coconut more like intravenous
[Music]
[Music]
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with [ __ ] Monday night looking
good [ __ ] uncle Joey coming action
October 16th whatever the [ __ ] it is
it's gonna be a beautiful [ __ ] night
look at the size of this but I'm gonna
bust out here look at this from the one
I jus look at this you know what the
name of this weed is fire are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what
you follow me we got everything tonight
we got nicotine gum
we got TKOs we got [ __ ] Shroomish is
right here I'm gonna give me the
prettiest one make sure I'm gonna do the
heavy one how the respect cuz I love you
you don't saying who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with here it's that type
of night at 20:20 Voodoo Lounge you
follow me we ain't [ __ ] around
tonight it's good taste it take a chance
Columbus didn't you know I'm saying it's
good good perfect don't have been down
that street before let's open up a
little bong hit here for uncle Lee to
get him in the [ __ ] mood you know
same wah wah wah wah wah wah wah wah wah
but what the [ __ ] let's do some aperitif
I get the party started
[Music]
one two three and I do great for
fighting we're gonna open up with a
thousand right off the bat
cuz that's how we roll in tonight you
still think it's a special holiday its
ooh calm in tonight here and the church
calendar you say it's super Lambie
tonight I don't give a [ __ ]
grandma it's your night start sucking
that helmet got something [ __ ] bingo you
gotta earn [ __ ] old dick when he comes
alright all-time favorite [ __ ] out
Black Sabbath songs hands of doom this
is now I'm given to me by one of my
goombazz and [ __ ] Tampa this weekend
the album covers a little [ __ ] up the
rats got to it but the album is
beautiful you some saying what you're
gonna do Lee Times caught up with you
[ __ ] wedgie and you're already
puking no all right let's get this party
started let's do that mushroom let's get
this [ __ ] thing gone look at this
[ __ ] thing look at this wall I don't
get nervous for dick anymore you
understand me and nothing but a [ __ ]
G thing baby there's no nervous that's
what put you that's what gives you a bad
trick you gotta go into with a smile on
your face card it's gonna be a beautiful
night you said that stressing yeah
rubbing your neckline but the [ __ ]
get it up the ass give us your [ __ ] I
still got it
on a Monday night you don't forget to
get dealing with Johnny novice it's time
for another but what are you doing why
you stopping we have we got records to
pay
now we have not got a keyboardist we got
records to break it I'm calling I got I
got Ripley on the phone
I got Ripley on the phone we ain't
[ __ ] around - lady I'm saying so the
rest is up to you [ __ ] who said bong
hit uncle Joey said [ __ ] him I was a
little [ __ ] Momo type bong it the
thing clogged up on me I'm sorry I
insulted you people with that [ __ ]
bucket I should be ashamed of myself
lady ready for Bangladesh is your name
if you get your throwing off I'm gonna
give you a piece of this but take it to
the [ __ ] next nothing is some same
here we go this is the jam this is I
used to take acid and listen to this
[ __ ]
you know you must be blind to do the
things like this to take a suite that
you don't know you'll get very death a
kiss poor little fool now oh [ __ ]
are you kidding me you do a head acid
you turn off the lights and you put this
on and then you get back to me all right
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] come to you that night right
your mind is full of pleasure your bar
these looking in are you [ __ ] nuts
let's go Lee let's kick this [ __ ]
meal that's how we do let the food to
lounge so dry the acid bear don't stop
the beat now all right let's do it
bong hits for [ __ ] Jerry's kids
you're not breathing
[Music]
but that will last oh [ __ ]
it that's it but no c'mon we gotta fill
it up
[Music]
we gotta give him another pocket
that was her I was a fan of pipe on him
let's go finish those stars tip-top
Magoo yeah we only have a stored-program
we got cash as long as calling and
emailing [ __ ] just they fill them at
once with a pump
[Music]
if I call this fiance
[Music]
we got things to doing people to see we
have no more time for excuses songs and
dances and [ __ ] it's a man's world [ __ ]
it'll Sam Jesus that's just the stars no
I have you wait the mushroom look at him
look at him I like him I like the
attitude no these are fresh
these are [ __ ] clean I had the guy's
steam clean employ this little [ __ ] out
of it I'm set
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna eat a mushroom with
this edible together that's how you do
it you're following it why not
you're gonna get down get down this is
to get down okay that's right your skin
touch turning green oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
our holes are in your skin are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what what are you
doing Ozzie what are you doing over
there there you go we're going deep
[ __ ] to the end Yahoo if the 18
hang up now if not go get one of your
grandma's [ __ ] pill I don't give a
[ __ ] it's the end of a [ __ ] era
understanding we'll celebrate tonight
it's a celebration [ __ ] Jesus Christ you
still have another two stars
[Music]
that mushroom tasted like ten dead
[ __ ] [ __ ] not but you may sit with
the Audubon that goes down smooth
no biggie it's no biggie here listen you
readin worse [ __ ] you eat that lizard
food and [ __ ] don't taste good here we
are
Monday night there you go that's the
last Emily that's it [ __ ] and Hayley
with that are misused tougher than that
look at leave maker inventions look it's
a taco so we'll [ __ ] soak em in
California you know the breathe happy
relaxed it's nothing
[Music]
they goes this is if our world was
forced [ __ ]
three-three won't be puking on the
pumper wheeler say lazarum they go they
go he's going down ah then you're gonna
move a [ __ ] honey Molly I don't [ __ ]
but I can't help [ __ ] around no more
you understand me
you wanna [ __ ] around go watch another
podcast we're going deep like the wool
10:19 whatever the [ __ ] it is alright
it's time for another bummer then we'll
get this podcast started youtube.com / c
/ Joey [ __ ] biz is the place to
be what I'll see them doing a Monday
night the [ __ ] Yankees are winning
you know whatever let's do this right
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz my main
little brother Cassius Morris its
calling in live from [ __ ] Canada will
talk about the weekends activities may
be throwing some Harvey Weinstein talk
and then take it from there ya know yeah
we're gonna get a call from Cosby
ratting out on Harvey Weinstein that's
the next thing he's going to testify
against [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein that
Harvey Weinstein gave me with quaaludes
understand
[ __ ] it's Monday night if you ain't got
a couple bombs in you ain't [ __ ] [ __ ]
you want another mushroom no that's it
it's all over you call me out they said
you wanted to see the other side so we
gave you a stem the [ __ ] captain I
[Music]
hate a Muslim with a head I should be
doing people to see yonce
besides there are fairies where boots is
coming on a lot as long as house we're
told they didn't come
[Music]
look at the mushrooms made the spots go
away it's clogged again suck like it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
suck on like a tuber there you go you
got it there there you go you blew it
out there go oh [ __ ]
[Music]
nice and smooth tip-top of gold
don't forget I'll see you [ __ ]
Lexington Kentucky Thursday night on
comedy off Broadway listen the stars are
on their way right now they're gonna get
that [ __ ] Friday morning that place
look Thursday [ __ ] them one of the stars
to get there thank you
Thursday morning the shipments getting
the [ __ ] Tuscaloosa and we'll be
bouncing off the walls at comedy off
Broadway Lexington Kentucky Thursday
night [ __ ] don't forget about You
uncle Joey youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz is the place to be ten minutes see
you there we love you [ __ ]
[Music]